your majesty
prime minister diameter ministers
CEOs of ineos and Winter Soldier
distinguished guests I'm delighted to
join you virtually for this project
launch
this is a big moment for Europe's green
transition
and for our clean tech industry
the first ever full value chain for
carbon capture and storage in Europe
you're showing that it can be done
that we can grow our industry through
Innovation and competition
and at the same time remove carbon
emissions from the atmosphere
through Ingenuity and cooperation
ladies and gentlemen this is what
Europe's competitive sustainability is
all about
let me Begin by once again applauding
our Danish hosts and friends for their
long-standing green leadership
in the 1970s
Denmark began investing in offshore wind
50 years later
thanks to this foresight
we have a Time proven solution to
Europe's energy security
last year for the first time ever wind
and solar produced more electricity in
Europe than any fossil source
and not just that
we are now also using the depleted oil
and gas fields in the North Sea to send
carbon back down into the ground
it shows once again that the North Sea
is increasingly playing a crucial role
in Europe's Net Zero future
this is a story worth sharing
it's a European success story of
cross-border Corporation
CO2 that is captured in Belgium and soon
Germany
is loaded onto ships in the port of
antivir Bruges
and Stuart thanks to Danish pioneering
spirit
it is a story
that involves dozens of European small
businesses
research institutes and Industrial
champions
a European value chain at its best
this project helps our industry as well
as the climate
the green sand project aims to store
safely and permanently
up to 8 megatons of CO2 per year by
2030.
just to put that into perspective
this corresponds to over 10 percent
of Denmark's current annual CO2
emissions
or the yearly carbon footprint
of nearly 1 million Danish citizens
so this project is a significant step
towards European carbon neutrality
and the science is clear
industrial carbon removal is a necessary
part of our climate toolbox
the International Energy agency
and the un's intergovernmental panel on
climate change are on the same page
to keep global temperatures below 1.5
degrees we need to remove Carbon on top
of our efforts to reduce emissions
because for the European Union
to become climate neutral
we need to industrially store around 300
megatons of CO2 annually by 2050.
this is a staggering amount
but you are showing how it can be done
with European cooperation
as this project demonstrates the
tremendous know-how we have in Europe
it is one of the key assets that will
help us build the infrastructure and the
economy of tomorrow
supporting Europe's clean tech sector is
a priority for the European Commission
that's why I have just proposed a new
green deal industrial plan
we are making full use of our single
Market
which will lead to economies of scale
and further bring down costs
we're simplifying regulation
to incentivize Technologies
such as carbon removal and to speed up
permitting
we're supporting with investment
from research and development with
Horizon Europe
to scaling up cleantech with the
Innovation fund
so far we have awarded over 2.8 billion
euros for 24 industrial decarbonization
projects
a new innovation fund call is open with
a record 3 billion Euro budget
and later this year the commission will
publish a comprehensive strategy on
carbon capture use and Storage
ladies and gentlemen
we have started a mission to secure
Europe's industrial Edge
create good and meaningful jobs
and fix our planet
carbon removal is part of this mission
I would like therefore
to thank everyone involved in this
project it is thanks to Pioneers like
you
that Europe is leading the way in the
race to net zero emissions
thank you very much for that